hello and welcome to this presentation
on the 8th edition of the guide an
environmental impact I'm John bradfield
senior director at a lack international
and I'm pleased you joined us today to
discuss a very important document in the
field of laboratory animal medicine a
bit of background on me before we get
started so you know who's sitting before
the camera here I'm a veterinarian with
a PhD in experimental pathology I've
been in laboratory animal medicine
academia through my whole career then
associated with a lack international for
well over 15 years doing site visits on
the council accreditation and on the
staff at a lack for about three years so
that's a brief history of my career and
with that I think will forge ahead and
discuss this important document just a
brief overview on the agenda here will
touch on the evolution of the guide and
how it got to where it is today touch on
its influence how it's used and then
dive down into the weeds a bit on key
points in chapters one through five
things that we deal with on a daily
basis here at a lack and things that we
see the institutions deal with and
sometimes challenged by with regard to
this document and how to manage the
programs so the God originally published
in 1963 a good while ago it was not
entitled the guide for the care and use
of laboratory animals but laboratory
animal facilities and care its focus in
those days was primarily laboratory
animal facilities and husbandry programs
and as you can see on the right hand
side of this slide the revisions that
have occurred over the years and namely
the growth in the document and its
content and the scope of topics that it
covers has indeed grown when we look at
the eighth edition published in 2011 we
see that it almost doubled in size
that's in part I think due to the 15
year time span between 1996 and 2011
field laboratory animal medicine and
science groom endlessly during that time
so the guy had a lot of work to do to
sort of encompass that growth and bring
those standards into print so 154 pages
of content in this 8th edition of the
guide and it has had a remarkable impact
I think on how programs are managed and
the standards by which we judge programs
and their acceptability if we jump back
to the 96 guide I think there was a
watershed moment that occurred with the
publication of that particular document
and that is a captured here I think on
page three with this statement it's
relatively simple but it really had a
profound impact on the use of this
document that continues today and that
is that the guy charges the users of
research animals with responsibility
achieving specified outcomes but it
leads how to accomplish these goals up
to the user in other words a performance
based approach that was a new concept in
1996 and it took programs and directors
of programs and scientists a bit of time
to adjust to this notion that there is
now some flexibility in how we meet the
standards rather than focusing on
exactly how the standards are met in
some sort of dictated fashion by the
document so that changed in 1996 but
then also went on to say that
performance goal places increasing
responsibility on the user and results
in interpretation in other words mainly
the aya cook is tasked with interpreting
the guide the language of the guy what
does it mean how do we implement those
standards at our current institution and
how do they apply that also is a new
concept and that flexibility was a bit
uncomfortable for many programs we
certainly had to adapt how we use the
guide and evaluate programs here at a
lack during that time I'll say here at
the outset that many of my remarks will
be very a lack oriented and that's both
inevitable and intentional I think it's
inevitable because I have had so much
experience of looking at programs
through a lack and working with a lack
but I would offer that a lack uses this
document in a way that no one else does
we take the standards of the guide and
the language of the guide around the
world as we accredit Animal Care and Use
programs we live and breathe this
language every day then the Council on
Accreditation has gone to great lengths
to understand every nuance easier said
than done but I would contend that we
use this document like no other it's a
key part of what we do every day and so
much of what you'll hear from me is the
a life perspective I hope you find that
a valuable so this illustration on the
slide here is meant to simply say that
the guide is not a roadmap it does not
tell us how to accomplish the standards
and how we meet those goals it simply
outlines the goals and leaves the
destination to them up to us that's an
important concept this performance
standards requires judgment professional
judgment it's a coordinated effort among
many people in the program and it
basically outlines the target or the
goal for example a very straight forward
claiming the guide that cages should be
regularly sanitized and cleaned seems
like a very straightforward process but
it makes no mention as to exactly how we
do that you can invest in very highly
technological cage washers or you can do
it by hand in a sink ultimately how well
it works is based on the professional
judgment and the performance based
approach at the institution each can
work equally well but obviously very
different procedures the guide is filled
with that kind of flexibility and that
creates a bit of a challenge sometimes
even though we appreciate that a
flexibility in addition to this
performance based approach there is
language in the guide that offers sort
of additional interpretation about how
it's used
this language directly from the guide
states that the guide is intentionally
written in general terms that it
requires professional judgment to
interpret the language of the guide and
that I cooks namely or ethical
committees or ethics committees
oversight bodies whatever you call that
committee with a primary role of
oversight in your institution has a key
role in interpretation implementation
and oversight as well as the ultimate
evaluation of the program itself so the
guide place is the responsibility of
implementation directly on the shoulders
of the attica so this notion of
performance standards in the fact that
the guide is written in general terms
can be both a blessing and a curse we
find sometimes we get take great comfort
in the fact that a document will tell us
not only what to do but how to do it
there's little room for interpretation
in such a scenario and we may not like
it at least we understand it and we do
it the guide is not that kind of
document it allows us to interpret and
employ a variety of flexible measures to
attain the goal so that creates
confusion it creates debate discussion
this creates a workload associated with
implementation and understanding the
guide so I would offer that it's both a
blessing and a curse we like the
flexibility that the guide offers that
we can achieve a goal in many different
ways but it also creates some
consternation in that we have to figure
out how to do that I think with the
advent of the performance standards back
in 1996 and the language of the guide
that reflected the performance based
approach it it became a worldwide
document a few of the Burton language
translations of the guide are listed
here on the screen included Chinese
Japanese Turkish Russian French German
thai so this document was translated
back in nineteen ninety six too many
regions of the world owing to its
written in general terms approach
meaning that it can be applied in almost
the Animal Care program hence its
utility hence its impact around the
world and part of the reason why a lack
uses it at one of its three primary
standards as we go around the world to
evaluate animal care programs the 8th
edition of the guide is well on its way
to translation in many languages and so
I think as time goes on that number of
languages will grow and the use of the
document will also continue to grow
around the globe so it really has a
worldwide impact well let's move on and
investigate some of the details down in
the we'd sort details in this document a
general overview here of the 8th edition
of the guide the 2011 guide it's written
in five chapters previous version was
for chapter 1 introduces key concepts
and sort of the fundamental foundation
approach to the rest of the chapters
including animal care news program
environment housing and management
veterinary care and physical plant with
a pretty hefty list of appendices to
support the language in the guide in all
this language is based on published data
scientific principles but also on expert
opinion and professional experience
these latter two aspects caused some
consternation among the scientific
community the belief being that the the
only relevant information ought to be
validated in the peer-reviewed
literature well the guide simply extends
its recommendations beyond what may be
in the peer-reviewed literature to
include expert opinion and experience in
judgment this makes folks a little
uncomfortable but the guide does this
very intentionally and it's probably
another reason why it grew so much from
the 96 version to the 2011 version in
that as our understanding of animals and
their biology and laboratory animal
medicine grows and our professional
experience grows the document needs to
reflect that
so chapter one here key concepts I'll
touch briefly on this there's sort of
broad brushstrokes of guiding principles
of the guide most of us are very
familiar with this but I'll touch on
them briefly and then we'll move on to
nity the real meat of the document so
applicability the guide lists of its
audience and in short it basically
encompasses everyone certainly I cooks
veterinarians investigators primary
audience and a guide but also mentions
the public we we don't forget the public
but I think it's appropriate that guide
mentions that everyone has a stake in
the standards of animal care and so the
guide authors believe it applies to
virtually everyone for the first time
the guide directly references the 3 r's
this isn't a new concept three hours
have always been a background and a
basis for the guy but for the first time
the language includes the three hours
and sort of reemphasize is the
importance of our use of the 3 r's as we
think about laboratory animal welfare it
defines the scope of the program the
animals their use the policy standards
and procedures and the personnel the
facilities it's a very broad definition
and they do that intentionally because
the scope of the program often includes
many different people with different
areas of expertise as a section on
policy so I think that's important
particularly with regard to the iock up
the guide cautions us to it particularly
the ayah cook to provide leadership in
the program and part of the way that the
I cook does that is through the
development of institutional policy to
implement the guide and the I cooks
interpretation of the guy and these are
all sorts of policies relative to the
use of the 3 r's 2 Surgery surgical
procedures husbandry procedures and the
like so the I cooks challenged with
developing policies which provide
guidance to the scientific community and
institution
terms oh boy there's been a lot of
discussion about these key terms
particularly must should and may people
have counted them and compared them to
previous versions and there's so many
new musts that are now required in a
guide and there's hundreds of shoulds
and what do these mean and how should
they be interpreted I think that's a
healthy discussion but I think counting
them and getting wrapped up in the
semantics may not be ultimately that
beneficial it is certainly there are
terms that we must pay attention to and
incorporate into our thinking but they
shouldn't become centerpoint into how we
interpret the overall language of the
guide so I've listed on this slide here
many of the current topics in the guide
the current version of the guide in
chapter 2 entitled the Animal Care and
Use program this is a lady chapter it
covers a wide variety in terms of
breadth and scope of topics both to I
cook function but also to occupational
health and safety and a number of issues
related to reviewing protocols so we'll
touch on a few of these as we go through
obviously we don't have time to do them
all free to do this document justice we
would probably be here for a week then
you might not tolerate that time frame
too well so we're going to condense this
dramatically down into one hour or
shorter presentation so these I think
are some of the key areas that we at a
lack see programs deal with struggle
with we'd get questions about these and
so I've highlighted these as wants to
cover in this presentation the guide
indicates now that there is an approach
to program management animal program
management which is collaborative or
ought to be collaborative and this is a
maybe it's not a new concept but its
newly articulated this collaborative
approach involves the I cook the
attending veterinarian institutional
official and by implication the
scientific community or the P
I so there's a charge now for regular
communication among the eyecup the AV
and the aisle institutional official
attending veterinarian and there's a
clearly a collaborative relationship
that ought to be in place when managing
the overall program the guide clearly
states this we see the most successful
programs embrace this notion when it
works well it benefits the program
collaborations we get a lot of questions
about collaborations let's face it
animal use and research in general is
global and we collaborate with
colleagues around the globe in instances
where animal studies involve
collaboration where animal use may
include animals that are off-site and
the work is done at another location the
guide specifically indicates that went
in such cases there should have be a
formal written understanding such as an
MoU in place which documents who has
responsibility for the animals who's
responsible for their care the
veterinary care who can make judgments
about animal disposition which I cook at
which institution does the review and
has the oversight so the Memorandum of
Understanding spells out all those
details of day-to-day Animal Care and
Use that might slip through the cracks
otherwise when the animal uses shared
between two institutions we look for
that at a lack sign when we do site
visits to ensure that institutions have
thought about those sort of details when
the animal uses shared in two different
locations there is a lot of content in
this chapter to about occupational
health and safety too much for us to go
into much detail but I will tell you
that occupational health and safety
findings are one of the top most cited
areas on a lek site visits occupational
health and safety is a broad program at
the institution likely it involves many
people in a variety activities these are
difficult programs to administer and
hence there's a lot of ways to misstep
we see this on a lek site visits and we
return to the guide for guidance about
how we should manage and implement
occupational health and safety programs
with regard to animal use first among
these principles is job risk assessment
and hazard identification by virtue of
one's job what is the risks what are the
risks that they are exposed to in the
conduct of their job who does that
analysis and what is their training and
is that an ongoing or periodic analysis
let's face it the risks change jobs
change descriptions change and the
hazard ID must change with time second
point that the guide makes is there
there ought to be a personal risk
assessment portion of the Occupational
Health and Safety this also should be
periodic you can't do it just once and
call it good health professionals need
to do a personal risk assessment for
people with animal contact how do you
capture that group of people how do you
initiate their contact with the health
professionals these are all challenges
that we many people face and how to
accomplish but the guide is clear in its
an implication requirement that this be
part of an arc health program it all
lines controlling prevention strategies
a hierarchy for such things so how do
you protect personnel remember one is
proper facilities and equipment proper
design proper HVAC systems protective
equipment about safety cabinets and FEMA
lives in the like how are those used and
implemented and they should be the first
line of defense secondly effective
safety procedures and protocols what are
the procedures in place to manage
dealing with hazards such as animal use
or biosafety or chemicals or radiation
and then third and last according to
this hierarchy and a guide is the use of
personal protective equipment or PPE we
see a number of programs that use PPE
first and that can be a problem so using
the facility and procedures first
followed by PPE is the outline and the
guide and that's what we look for in a
lock site visits
there should be health professionals
associated with the program to provide
medical services this is not always the
case it seems fundamental but not all
programs have that in yours should
specific language in the guide dealing
with microbiologic hazards and and how
you should deal with those and the guide
specifically references the EMBL in such
cases there's language and a guide about
respiratory protection and fit testing
when respirators are required for use
and finally there should be a component
of occupational health and safety
training personnel should know the risks
they're faced with with the animals they
use and the procedures involved and the
kinds of studies they're involved with
that training should encompass those
facets the guide specifically references
the BM BL terms of microbiologic hazards
and we use that as a reference resource
on site visits so if you're using
Michael biologic hazards you should be
following the recommendations of the BM
BL haylock also uses the Occupational
Health and Safety and can use of
research animals this is an important
document that goes into a lot of detail
about how to set up and implement
occupational health programs now spend a
bit of time on this topic I've really
gone over it very quickly but I did that
intentionally because occupational
health and safety is one of those areas
that we see programs continually
challenged to effectively implement we
spent a lot of time on site visits
evaluating these facets of the program
in addition to occupational health and
safety is the topic of I cook function
and namely protocol review so if we look
at site visit findings the second really
it's just about it so as frequent as
occupational health and safety issues
are issues associated with the I cook or
ethics committee relative to protocol
review half of all I cook related
findings on site visits relate to
protocol review or
ineffective or gaps in protocol review
the guy has additional language in this
version compared to the 96 version on
the kinds of things that I cook should
consider during protocol review and
there's a bulleted list in chapter 2
which lay that lays this out fairly
clearly and I'll cover this briefly this
type here in red are the that is the new
language in the 2011 version namely that
there'd be a concise sequential
description of the procedures involving
the use of animals should be easily
understood by all members of committee
that seems very straightforward that
this can be challenging to accomplish in
some protocols they're complex and so
sometimes the committee may not have a
full understanding of the animal use if
that occurs we think that's a problem in
addition there is new language in this
bulleted list relative to group sizes
and the number of animals required and
the fact that the statistical
justification is ideal when it can be
done in addition to that there's a new
bullet point on the impact of the
proposed procedures on the animals
well-being coined another way this could
be a cost-benefit analysis or they're
like we use the term harm benefit but
that's considering the overall value and
need to do the scientific investigation
based on the impact of animal well-being
and animal health oh there should be
description of surgical procedures and
particularly descriptions of
post-surgical and post procedural care
for the animals as well as a description
for the rationale and anticipated
selected endpoints we believe this is
both experimental endpoints described in
the protocol as well as humane endpoints
described in the protocol we look very
carefully at protocols to see if it
encapsulate these basic functions I'll
touch more on that later on also in this
list long-lived species
perhaps their final disposition when the
research project is completed and
considerations for options for long live
species that's new language in the guide
and then a provision for the use of
hazardous materials and safe working
environment that was there but not in so
many words in the previous version in
addition to that bulleted list there's a
number of topics that the guide labels
special considerations for protocol
review and again we see the experimental
and humane endpoints unexpected outcomes
and the light you could see the list
here on the screen and I'll touch on a
few of these because we've had quite a
bit of discussion at a lack in the
council itself but also a lot of
questions from institutions about how
these special considerations are
implemented during protocol review what
do they involve I'll step back to the
forty thousand foot level here this is a
sort of a ridiculous slide is probably
too small for you to read and I listed
here only for illustrative purposes in
the US this is a west of required
elements of protocol review by the I
cook now not all protocols will involve
this entire list but just looking at the
number of bullet points on this list
sort of underscores the complexity and
the workload involved that I cooks are
faced with to follow these tenants in
the guide I've also listed some from the
animal welfare regulations here but in
the u.s. both of those apply and I cooks
are obligated to follow them this is no
small task in fact before I go into this
next topic I think that underscore is
one of the main take-home points that
I'd like to make and that when you think
about impact of the eighth edition of
the guide i think the i cook has to be
foremost in your thinking i contend that
it is the single most impacted group of
individuals with this revision of the
eighth edition of the guide the I cook
simply has a tremendous workload to
implement
all that's in this document secondly
would of course be the investigator so
we have to keep these two groups in mind
when we look deep into the content a bit
about harm benefit analysis get a lot of
questions about that equivalent term
would be cost benefit but it stems we
believe from this statement here on page
27 of the guide that you see on the
screen the ayah cook is obliged to weigh
the objectives of the study its
potential animal welfare concerns while
this is newly articulated in the guide
we don't believe this is it all a new
concept in fact it's a basic premise on
which I cooks and ethics committees have
been based since their inception the
guide simply now articulates that in no
uncertain terms that part of what the I
cook ought to do is consider the
potential harms or costs of doing the
research against the potential benefit
this does not necessarily need you I
could do some sort of special analysis
this is inherent in the judgment and the
careful analysis that any protocol or
the goes during review and so it's not
necessarily anything special but it's
something that should be sort of in the
back of our minds whenever we review
protocols and for protocols that involve
the potential for pain and distress this
analysis gets even more important and
capturing the I cooks consideration of
these issues is often beneficial either
in the minutes or in questions back to
the p.i but understanding that i cooks
do this is part of the site visit
process humane endpoints another topic
in the guide that is now more specific
in terms of language critical aspect for
protocols with a potential for pain and
distress they should be clearly defined
in the protocol humane endpoints that is
their determination should involve the
p.i the veterinarian and the I cook
before the study starts the guide says
there are four critical criteria when
evaluating human points or establishing
humane endpoints number one a precise
definition as precise as possible the
old terminology of say
moribund may not meet this definition
that can be a vague term and it means
different things to different people so
describing clinical conditions for
example that the animals will exhibit
when they reach a humane endpoint is
likely important secondly frequency of
observations how often will these
animals be observed to see if they're
reaching their endpoint and what is the
training of the personnel making these
observations will they recognize the
endpoint and lastly do they know what
the required actions are when the end
point is reached these four critical
areas are outlined in the guide this
comes directly from the guide and a lack
look specifically for these and that I
cooks consider these during protocol or
renew this like to smile a little bit
whenever I see this topic because boy it
has received a lot of discussion and a
lot of concern on part of scientific
community and and rightly so I think the
guide has new language that indicates
that whenever possible pharmaceutical
grade substances should be used I think
well I know that we had a lack and and I
also suspect that the authors of the
guide did not intend for that statement
to include such things as test articles
by the very nature there may not be a
pharmaceutical mass-produced product
that can be used for a test article by
their very nature they're in development
it's the point of the study it's part of
the variables that are under research so
it may not apply easily this requirement
for non-pharmaceutical for
pharmaceutical grade substances to test
articles but when it involves
medications particularly anesthetics
analgesics antibiotics things to promote
animal welfare well-being and welfare
pharmaceuticals ought to be used when
they're available women are available or
when they're inappropriate for use the I
cook is is free to approve non
pharmaceutical grade substances it's not
that we must use pharmaceutical grade
each and every time there's a product
available but we must consider them and
if they're inappropriate to you
for some reason that should be outlined
in the protocol and the I cook should
establish that whatever product is used
in a little before misu t'kul is safe
and effective how is it made is it
sterols the pH correct what's the shelf
life where its storage conditions those
are the things that the investigator in
the I cook should consider when
approving non-pharmaceutical great
substances again another workload issue
for the ayah cook but an important one
we get a lot of questions on this topic
in chapter 2 post-approval monitoring or
Pam the guide says that the continuing I
cook oversized required and it may help
promote and provide opportunities to
refine research procedures I think both
those things that are true this is a new
term listed in the guide although many
of us are familiar with it for a long
time now but the guide now references
this concept of post-approval monitoring
we get questions like well since it's
knowing the guide is is that requires
there's some sort of formal Pam program
that are I cook needs to institute in
order to be compliant with the guide
with a lack believe that that's not the
case that oversight can be accomplished
in any number of ways and having a
formal Pam program simply may not be
needed depends on the complexity and
scope of your program it can be the
semi-annual process it can be the I cook
providing oversight to any number of
mechanisms or it can be professional
personnel hired to do nothing but
post-approval monitoring on behalf of
nayuka so it runs the gamut in terms of
complexity and I would recommend that
you tailor this to your the needs of
your particular program smaller programs
that use few animals in a very narrow
area of research may not need of
well defined formal program the
post-approval monitoring whatever you do
I would caution the ayah co2 to avoid
the gotcha approach when doing oversight
in general and post-approval monitoring
it's not that we're necessarily trying
to catch investigators going astray
inevitably protocol dress occurs or
somebody may not understand the full
content of a protocol and oversight
visits can help catch those issues but
they should be done in the light of
working with investigators to keep them
in compliance with their protocols and
the policies of the institution and
doing that in a friendly manner is a
whole lot more effective than using the
gotcha approach so in summary in chapter
2 i've listed what i think are the main
responsibilities of the ayah cook and I
intentionally chose this white flag
waving image because in some ways this
is a daunting task very few I cooks are
composed of people dedicated only to the
ICO these are professionals who have
full-time jobs and to do what's required
on this list on the slide is no small
task and I think we need to understand
that that's probably one reason why I
occur findings are the most numerous on
elec site visits is because the scope of
work by the ayah cook is tremendous ok
let's move on to environment housing and
management of another lady chapter in
the guide this is chapter 3 it covers a
wide array of topics a lot of details
here about how we care for animals
basically describing husbandry programs
in their overall management I'll touch
on a few of these topics here as we move
through chapter 3 it's certainly not all
of them table 3.1 I think in some ways
it may be the most misunderstood table
and the guide this table lists
recommended drywall temperatures reckon
for most common laboratory animal
species
when you look at the values in this
table there is a very wide range and
some interpret this table meaning that
if the day to day temperature variation
occurs anywhere within the range if you
look at mouse rat hamster gerbil column
20 to 20 degree 26 degrees c 68 to 79
degrees Fahrenheit that's a very wide
range this is some folks interpret that
as long as the temperatures anywhere
within that range we're okay we're
meeting the standards of the guide and
we believe that that's a
misinterpretation of this table stable
is intended provide guidance on where
you establish the set point for your
temperature settings in your animal
rooms this is also language from the
guide and it specifically addresses this
issue of the table 3.1 their broad and
generally reflect tolerable limits not
day-to-day variation allowance animal
should have adequate resources for
behavioral thermoregulation ie bedding
or nest building and temperature should
be selected and maintained with minimal
fluctuation near the middle of these
ranges that's the a lack approach so you
should establish your set points where
the science and the animal biology
dictates and minimize the fluctuation of
day to day temperature fluctuation
around those set points the guide later
in chapter 5 indicates that plus or
minus 1 degrees C or two degrees
Fahrenheit is an appropriate range of
fluctuation that's a pretty minimal
range certainly much narrower than is
reflected in table 3.1 may be the most
talked about a topic in the 8th edition
of the guide certainly the Council on
accreditation is still discussing the
nuances of social housing and I think
many programs are too depending on the
species of animal this is a busy slide
to focus on the type in red here and
that the guide indicates that we should
account for the animals behavioral needs
their social needs that should be housed
in stable pairs and groups of compatible
individuals a should word again
there should be appropriate social
interactions in single housing of social
animals should be the exception so I've
sort of capsulize there a lot of
language in the guide that describes its
its requirement and approach for social
needs of animals we get a lot of
questions about this and basically the a
lack position is that social housing
should be the default if animals can't
be socially housed either due to
veterinary reasons or needs of the
science or because they're incompatible
fine but those instances should be
reviewed and documented by the I cook in
other words single housing should be
intentionally considered and the I cook
should give careful weight consideration
and social needs if they can't be met in
animal singly housed then that is
allowable as long as the I cook has
fully considered it we move on to
environmental enrichment and this is
fairly straightforward as well but
enrichment programs the guide says
should be reviewed by the I cook the
researchers in the veterinarian on a
regular basis so this is a periodic
review Oh to ensure that it's
appropriate as well as effective should
be updated as needed as we learn more
about appropriate enrichment strategies
for animals and people in the program
should be at least trained or
well-versed or understand the scope of
the environmental enrichment program and
what it entails specific points that we
consider here at a lack is that the all
animals in the program should be
considered when developing environmental
enrichment program not some animals
excluded and including others it should
be afforded to all animals in the
program at least to consideration for
environmental enrichment it should be
uniformly implemented across the program
knowing that in some cases environmental
enrichment may impact scientific
outcomes and may be inappropriate in
such cases enrichment may be withheld
this also should be a consideration of
the I occur
there's a need also we think to consider
personal safety and bio security with
enrichment items that hence the need for
ongoing review and assessment initially
this received quite a bit of discussion
this issue of cage in pen space we've
seen some issues with since we
implemented the use of the guide and
they lack site visit but it's driven not
to be that tricky for institutions many
people turned right two tables 3.22
through 3.6 these lists the various
species and the recommended starting
points for cage sizes and there was some
new language in these tables with regard
to mice and rats with litters and
non-human primates we should keep in
mind that these tables by their very
nature are engineering standards they
list recommended starting points the
guide also has a host of performance
standards or criteria listed in the
guide in the text and so we would
caution programs to read this section on
Cajun spins can pen space very
thoroughly because there's that has a
lot to say other than just the numbers
and engineering standards in those
tables so the briefly the performance
standards described in the guide one
here on the page that animals should be
able to make natural postures and
postural adjustments should have ready
access to food and water and comfortably
rest away from areas soiled by feces and
urine performance criteria socially
housed animals should have the ability
and enough space to escape aggression or
hi Kate I should take indicate postural
adjustments and clearance of from keys
from structures within the cage and
particularly the cage ceiling and final
example here is a particularly with
regard to rodents that there should be
sufficient space to allow the pups to
develop de leaning without detrimental
effects to either the mother or the
litter these are performance criteria
that institutions should consider when
establishing how to use the cages that
are in place let's focus less on the
size of the cage that's only
one aspect and focus on the the nature
of how that space in the cage is used
still in chapter 3 here a monitoring
effectiveness of sanitation I mentioned
a at the beginning this issue with
washing cages and each you can do this
in any number of ways and that's true
but you should establish a mechanism by
which you assess the effectiveness of
cage sanitation and the guide has clear
language on things to consider when
doing that and we see this a lot come up
during site visits as to how you know
your cages are cleaned whether you wash
them by hand or in a cage washer and
sometimes institutions don't know they
don't have systems in place to assess
effectiveness of sanitation some say and
I agree that the cage wash is the heart
of the animal facility because if it is
not working effectively you can get
spread of disease which impacts animal
health and scientific outcomes so it's a
critically important part and you should
know whether or not it works so
establishing some method maybe even a
microbiologic method is recommended by
the guy here to establish that your
cages are clean quickly moving through
veterinary care here and then the final
chapter of physical plant I'll touch on
a few more topics we're in Chapter four
now these are many of the main topics
that you see in chapter 4 and I'll cover
just a few of those I think of all the
chapters in the guy this one I would
argue changed the least in that many of
these concepts were in place in the
previous version of the guy I will cover
though the role of the attending
veterinarian they lack the site visits
around the world and we understand that
the role of the veterinarian in the
animal overall animal care news program
varies according to region and even
country in the US there's a statutory
requirement for an attending
veterinarian and their responsibilities
and their authorities this doesn't exist
in other countries and so they lack
really combed through the guide
carefully to determine what the guide
says about the responsibilities of the
attending veterinarian so this next set
Shin will highlight those areas and what
a lack looks for in the scope and
breadth of the veterinary care program
oddly enough or interestingly enough
many of these statements come from
Chapter two not in chapter four but
again this is the scope of the program
outlined in Chapter two and this is
where you'll find much of this language
so on page 13 you'll see that the
veterinarian is tasked along with the I
cook in the IO for oversight
responsibilities again that
collaborative approach while the IO
bears ultimate responsibility for the
program it is legally a shared
day-to-day management responsibility
among the aisle the attending
veterinarian in the I cook so the
attending veterinarian has day-to-day
program management responsibilities
program needs should be clearly and
regularly communicated to the iolite
attending veterinarian so this need for
collaboration and namely communication
ultimately the guide says on page 14 the
attending veterinarian is responsible
for the health and well-being of
laboratory animals I don't think anybody
would debate that but in some regions of
the globe veterinarians may or may not
have such direct impact on the health
and well-being of animals we look to see
that veterinarians do have that impact
in programs that we accredit continuing
on this topic of the guide as a
statement that indicates that the AV
should oversee other aspects of the
program in other words not just be
restricted to veterinary care but also
encompass husbandry programs housing of
animals we were talked about temperature
and set points the veterinarian is often
involved in establishing those so the
scope of expertise required of
veterinarians it's really quite large if
there is no full-time veterinarian to
God says that a veterinarian should be
available at appropriate intervals to
meet the needs of the program so how
often that consulting veterinarian
visits depends on the program itself but
should be frequent enough so that
veterinary care is effective and fully
implemented if there is no full-time
veterinarian someone at the institution
should be designated with assigned
responsibility for daily animal care use
and facility management
to coordinate with that veterinarian to
establish visits and veterinary care
emergency care and implement the overall
program of Veterinary Medicine with
regard to training I'll just touch on
this the guide has some statements that
the veterinarian must have experience
training and expertise necessary to
evaluate the species are the well-being
and health and the animals used that's a
must statement in the guide so we will
look to see that the training
requirements of attending veterinarians
are in place when we do site visits
initially veterinarians should also have
experience in training and laboratory
animal facility management and
administration you may also need
expertise in a whole variety of topics
so we can see that the guide tasks the
attending veterinarian with quite a
number of responsibilities so we look to
see the program's have recognized that
and place the veterinarian in a position
of authority to meet those
responsibilities finally in chapter 4
there's some verbiage about the role of
the attending veterinarian the
veterinary care is essential oversight
of the animals and their well-being
promoting animal well-being at all times
monitoring animal world doing at all
times and implementing a high quality
care and ethical standards so that comes
from chapter for itself the chapter on
veterinary care bart protocol review as
well as day-to-day management of animals
that are on study involves the
prevention or treatment of pain the guy
says it's an integral component of
veterinary medical care we they a lack
believe that and we look to see that the
veterinarian is closely involved in pain
management recommendations for
appropriate pain medications and
aesthetics and analgesics the guide
gives a nod here to pre-emptive
analgesia and in this notion of wind up
and preventing wind up so that we
prevent animal pain this is a basic
tenant of the guide with regard to
animal pain and it's a it's a core value
that a lot uses when we evaluate
programs and that is that the use of
anesthetics and analgesics is an ethical
and scientific imperative and so we
place a lot of importance on evaluating
programs with that in mind there should
be training and understanding and
awareness of recognizing clinical signs
and specific species and this runs the
gamut and it can be quite different from
species to species and veterinarians
know this but another core principle
that the guide has been based on for a
number of iterations but certainly in
this most recent one is that unless the
contrary is known if a procedure would
cause pain in humans we assume it causes
pain in animals and it is on that
premise that we evaluate protocols
establish pain relief regimens and
implement them make sure that they're
followed likewise the guide addresses
distress and it defines it as an
aversive state which animals fail to
cope or adjust to various stressors
implementation of clear appropriate and
humane experimental endpoints is
critical both to limiting distress as
well as pain and this gets back to those
four key principles of establishing
humane endpoints particularly for
protocols involve the potential for pain
lastly in this chapter is topic of
euthanasia the a lack council has
adopted the AMA guidelines on euthanasia
and the most recent iteration of that so
you should be very familiar with the
details of that we have had a lot of
questions about the AVMA guidelines and
how they're used and particularly about
co2 euthanasia for smaller species and
we find this this line in the guy that
says unless of deviation is justified or
scientific medical reasons methods of
euthanasia should be consistent with the
AMA guidelines specifically with regard
to co2 should used sources from
compressed gas cylinders a displacement
rate of ten to thirty percent volume per
min
avoid prefilled chambers and a method to
verify death those are key points
outlined in the AVMA guidelines and
those are things that we look for when
we look at procedures for the proper
euthanasia of animals last chapter is a
also a lady chapter and it covers
physical plant there's way too many
topics for us to address here but I'll
choose a few and then we'll wrap it up
this notion of animals in laboratories
so we call those satellites when animals
are maintained outside the animal
facility we expect that the basic
overall conditions and those satellite
facilities meet the same standards as
those required in animal facilities
themselves and the guide lends credence
to this notion with this statement on
the screen so wherever your housing
animals particularly outside the animal
facility you have to think about the
things that you normally would in the
animal facility security temperature
HVAC procedures for sanitation transport
back and forth to the satellite facility
occupational health and safety issues
with regard to animal allergy all those
facets that you would think about in the
animal facility also apply to satellites
one of the main areas in chapter 5 that
we see programs struggle with its HVAC
system function and it's complex these
are expensive systems they're often
delicate systems they can be fragile in
difficult to balance and maintain so we
see programs struggle with those but
with regard to hvac we expect that
temperature control be paramount because
when temperature control is not good
animal well-being suffers and maybe even
animal dust deaths result there should
be high temperature failsafe such as
recoils that fail in the closed position
a very effective monitoring of the
environment the animal room environment
the temperature and humidity air
pressure differentials alarm set points
so that when
temperatures get out of alarm
appropriate actions can be taken also
important with hvac system function is
ventilation air flow direction and then
assessing HVAC function periodically at
a likely require this every three years
and also that the HVAC system function
at some minimal level even during power
outages I'll note here that when we
analyze the kinds of disasters recorded
to a lack and and where they occurred is
it flood is it fires a hurricane what is
it we know that over the last five years
seventy one of the disasters 71 percent
and the disasters reported a lag we're
the result of HVAC or some other system
malfunctioned so far and away the
biggest category of disasters that
impact animal welfare occur within the
facility itself namely that HVAC system
so whatever attention you pay to
maintaining that system is is is good
and well founded Rock wash your safety
the guide says that we should consider
personnel safety and these pieces of
equipment they're dangerous and
sometimes even deadly at a lack we have
three four basic tenants to implement
this safety and that is ease of egress a
device inside the chamber that will stop
the flow of the water the energizing
device and the people be person to be
well trained in the training devices
themselves lastly that the safety
features on the machine be labeled with
signage that's legible signs that
indicate where on the door to push to
open it from the inside not on the
inside for example a tag on the cable to
turn off the water in the chamber should
be a sign identifying that so those are
the key points that a lack looks for to
meet this standard in the guide
I mentioned that environmental
monitoring but this is key automated
systems are recommended this is a
statement from the guide they should
function basically 24 7 365 weekends
holidays middle of the night you can do
this with manual methods and some small
facilities managed to do this but it's
challenging to do this manually say with
personnel walking through the facility
at off hours it's fraught with problems
and difficult to achieve so automated
systems are recommended there should be
appropriate call-out mechanism to warn
personnel that issues arise at any time
so the appropriate action can be taken
so where you set your alarm set points
is important the ability to notify
personnel continuous coverage and
monitoring temperature and conditions at
the room level are all key features we
look for not monitoring at the building
level but at the room level where the
animals are so with that I think will
summarize and then try to address a few
questions so the guides are
intentionally written in general
language it uses performance standards
and allows us latitude on how we
implement this is a little uncomfortable
for us sometimes because we have to
understand the guide we have to be smart
about what the content of the guide is
and what the language says and we have
to implement that correctly this is has
a significant impact on our cooks namely
and investigators as well if I cooks
continually over-interpret requirements
of the guide this can really increase
regulatory burden at the institutional
level and we see this all the time so I
cooks need to be really smart about what
the guide says and when the guide gives
us flexibility and we should use that
flexibility to the benefit of the
program we look at those key facets of
our cooks we think about protocol review
Nativity thorough and detailed and
careful that there'd be some mechanism
for program oversight that this is
ongoing whether the semi-annual
processor
approval monitoring program there should
be a robust occupational health and
safety program please look environment
and housing and management social
housing environmental enrichment and
Kate space are key issues for
consideration the I cook should be
involved in making those policies and
decisions about those key aspects of the
environment veterinarian has a
multi-faceted role particularly
important as we go around the globe and
specifically managing pain and distress
we just completed the physical plant
portion hvac hvac a track because it has
such profound implications with regard
to animal well-being satellite
management and Cajun rack washer safety
are also key key aspects to that
physical plane with that I will wrap up
I think we're pretty close to the end of
our time but I'm going to see what sort
of questions we we have and scroll
through these there's a question about
co2 euthanasia and whether or not a lack
requires the co2 chamber to be
physically evacuated before placing
other animals in the chamber it's a good
question and I'll caveat make a caveat
point here at the beginning that the
elec Council is still working through
some of these fine details so you have
to stay tuned on this one I think the
answer of evacuating the chamber depends
on how it's used how much time between
batches and euthanasia so if the top was
off the chamber and there's a potential
for a lot of room air to be mixed with
the co2 in a chamber effectively
evacuating it just by a normal usage
maybe you don't need to evacuate that
chamber on the other hand if the next
batch of animals is going in immediately
after the first batch was removed maybe
evacuation would be required the point
is not to exceed that ten to thirty
percent displacement rate recommended in
a guidelines those were recommended
based on peer-reviewed literature about
wind pain and nociception occurs at
around that thirty percent rate so
exceeding
that may induce animal pain and distress
is it possible to approve the use of
sodium pentobarbital for all studies in
one organization this is an interesting
one because this drug has essentially
been made unavailable due to its expense
hola has recognized that and I think the
USDA as well and I think that's a
decision that the ire cook can make if
the drug is so expensive is to be
rendered virtually inaccessible and
sodium pentobarbital is required for the
conduct of certain procedures then
alternatives can be made available in
the I cook could establish a policy on
how that can be done effectively
guidelines for what to use how to use it
how to prepare it and how to make sure
it's safe and effective there's a
question here I think can you restate
the four criteria protocol review that a
lack specifically looks at and what page
n and guided maybe I think this might
refer to two main endpoints I'll test
myself here and see if I can recall them
off the top of my head if I understand
the question correctly number one
consideration is a precise definition of
the endpoint what the animals will be
experiencing and a clinical signs that
will be observed precise number two
what's the frequency of observation of
those animals as they get more painful
or sicker the frequency might need to
increase and so discussions like that
would be important the training of
personnel that will be making those
observations and animals what do they
know can they recognize the end point
when they see it and finally what is the
action that they are required to take
when when the end point is reached
bear with me while I look through the
question was here and trying to scroll
up for additional questions I'm thinking
this question might also pertain to co2
euthanasia i'm not sure but the question
is if it is necessary is it necessary to
put only one animal in the cage and what
you recommend the AVMA guidelines are
not real specific on the number of
animals to be placed in a euthanasia
chamber at a time I think we could all
agree that placing too many animals in
the chamber would be problematic I think
more germane and well as least germane
to the number of animals is mixing
animals that may be unfamiliar
particularly with rodents there can be
aggression in fighting a tremendous
distress associated with mixing batches
of rodents in that co2 chamber certainly
having enough space so that each animal
has floor surface area and and that
they're not overcrowded would be
critical so considering overcrowding
however you define that as well as
avoiding mixing animals of different
sources that might be unfamiliar with
each other inside and fighting and
aggression those are key points to keep
in mind how exactly you do that it was
probably a institutional decision but
it's something that should be considered
we would not say that only one animal in
the cage at a time would be required but
again the caveat is that the council is
still discussing the finer details of a
wax expectations there so stay tuned for
the what we look for on co2 requirements
how do you say
appropriate time to do post-approval
monitoring and who should be in charge
of it well the guy places that
responsibility ultimately on the
shoulders of the ayah cook the I cook is
tasked with program oversight how do you
accomplish that oversight does not
necessarily mean that the active members
themselves must do it typically they'll
involved members the veterinary staff
may be operations manager and other
people very familiar with the facilities
as well as sometimes dedicated staff to
do nothing but post-approval monitoring
they can act on behalf of the I cook
provide reports and information to the I
code but ultimately it's the I cook
that's responsible for doing that the
frequency of that may depend on the
nature in the work of the studies
involved the more invasive or tricky the
studies are perhaps the more frequent
visits ought to be surgery for example
if there's a laboratory doing surgery
you might visit that lad more frequently
then if animals are simply brought to
the lab say for blood pressure cuff
measurements of three times a week
there's a difference in those kind of
procedures and a frequency and a
hierarchy of when you visit them like
certainly be very appropriate I think
that brings us to the to the end of our
time and so I think it may be time to to
sign off I appreciate your attention in
your attendance I hope this brief
overview of the guide was helpful and
thanks for joining us
you